♪ ("LAST WEEK TONIGHT"
THEME MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Our main story tonight
concerns drugs.
You know, the substances
that gave us most music,
seasons one and two
of The West Wing,
and this spectacular clip
of a BBC reporter
getting inadvertently wasted.
Burning behind me is eight
and a half tons of heroin,
opium, hashish,
and other narcotics.
(GIGGLES)
Burning behind--
Shh! Quick, quick, quick,
we just need one more.
(GIGGLES)
Exquisite.
That deserves the Pulitzer Prize
for Reporter on Most Drugs.
I'm not sure what
my favorite part is there.
His little giggle,
the idea that someone thought,
"Let's put a guy downwind from
an eight and a half ton
pile of burning narcotics,"
or the fact that its main effect
on him seems to be
to turn him into
a total sweetie pie.
Specifically, we're gonna
talk about psychedelics.
A category that includes
drugs like psilocybin,
LSD, and MDMA.
And let me first say, I know
anyone with my face, voice,
and generally off-putting aura
who talks about drugs
is usually warning you about
the devil's lettuce.
But I'm no fucking narc.
In college, I practically
majored in herbology
with a minor in ganjaneering.
They called me
Sonic the Hedgehog
'cause I rolled tightly.
Also, I've done blow on tour
with Ozzy Osborne,
who's also my dad by the way,
so I'm in the scene, okay?
I get it.
The truth is,
lots of people use psychedelics.
Some for spirituality,
some for healing,
and some like A$AP Rocky
just for fun.
The first time that he did LSD,
it started to kick in
just as he was having sex,
with some surprising
consequences.
No lie,
a rainbow shot out of my dick.
And it had a sound with it
like... (MIMICS PIANO RUN)
Like a piano or some shit.
I have no idea why
there was a rainbow
coming out of my penis.
I don't even like rainbows.
Excellent.
Every sentence is better
than the last there.
"A rainbow shot out of my dick,"
fantastic.
"It had a sound with it
like a piano or some shit,"
I love it.
"I have no idea
why there was a rainbow
coming out of my penis,"
now he's introduced suspense
to the story.
"I don't even like rainbows,"
what a way to stick the landing.
Also, I'm pretty sure
that A$AP Rocky
just gave Skittles
their next commercial.
"Skittles,
taste the dick rainbow."
♪ (PIANO RUN) ♪
But tonight, we're gonna focus
on one particular use
of psychedelics.
In therapy.
It's a field that you may
have heard about recently
in stories featuring
testimonies
from some very satisfied
patients.
I had all this access
to my mind
and I could control
where I was thinking and going.
It connected me back to my body.
Like I could feel my body again.
It made me feel more comfortable
with living, you know.
Because you're not afraid
of dying.
It's like doing therapy
while being hugged
by everyone who loves you
in a bathtub full of puppies
licking your face.
Wow.
That is a pretty
powerful endorsement.
He makes it sound
pretty nice there.
It would sound nicer
if a rainbow also
shot out of your dick,
but that's only
because A$AP Rocky
has now raised the bar
in what constitutes
a pleasant human experience.
That last guy is a veteran
who claims psychedelic treatment
not only helped him with PTSD,
but saved his life.
And he's not the only vet
who has benefitted.
C.J. HARDIN: I had three
experiences at full dosage.
But the effects
after the first treatment
were profound.
I would've said
a 60 percent reduction
in my symptoms immediately.
I felt a mighty change
had occurred.
Sixty percent immediately.
It is not often you see
those kind of results
after your first
therapy session.
Especially now that so much
of it happens over Zoom.
Usually, day one is spent
for introductions
and trying to figure out
what the fuck that thing
behind your therapist's head is.
That can't be
what I think it is, right?
It just can't be.
And look,
it's not just anecdotal.
A recent clinical trial
of MDMA assisted therapy
found that for those
suffering from PTSD,
just two months after treatment,
67 percent no longer qualified
for a PTSD diagnosis.
And that is not even
getting into the promise
that psychedelics have shown
in treating conditions
like addiction and depression.
The fact is, all of this
is hugely encouraging,
but it is worth knowing
we've actually been here
before with psychedelics,
and we fucked it up.
And if we are not very careful
in the years ahead,
we could go backwards again.
So tonight, let's talk about
psychedelic therapy.
Its history, its potential,
and what the pitfalls ahead
might be.
And let's begin by acknowledging
a lot of these medicines,
especially psilocybin,
are nothing new
to Indigenous communities.
They've been conducting
rituals involving mushrooms,
peyote, ayahuasca,
and other ceremonial medicines
far longer than
Western civilization has.
But interesting psychedelics
outside of
Indigenous communities
really picked up around
the middle of the last century.
LSD was first synthesized
in a Swiss lab in 1938.
And a banker at JP Morgan
named R. Gordon Wasson
popularized magic mushrooms
after hearing about
an Indigenous Mexican woman
named Mariá Sabina,
who used them
in healing ceremonies,
and tracked her down in 1955.
SPEAKER: After several attempts,
he finally convinces
Mariá Sabina to let him taste
the magic mushrooms,
as they came to be called.
He comes back and writes
an account of his adventure
that is published
in Life Magazine of all places.
Now, this is astonishing.
This is 1957 when it comes out.
Thousands of words
in the biggest magazine
in America.
This article,
when it's published,
is a sensation.
It's true.
Wasson was basically
the very first white guy
who did shrooms and then made it
his entire personality.
That article started a stampede
of hippies and celebrities
into Mariá Sabina's village
that turned her neighbors
against her to such a point
that they burned her house
to the ground.
So you can add magic mushrooms
to the list of things
completely ruined
by finance bros
along with vests, dating apps,
and the middle class.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
But it wasn't just bankers
and hippies
drawn to the power
of these substances.
The U.S. military actually
conducted experiments
to see if they could be
dropped on enemy troops
to incapacitate them.
And lucky for us,
they filmed those experiments
for posterity.
NARRATOR: Here is a group
of normal soldiers
responding correctly
to a series
of routine drill commands.
After receiving a small dose
of LSD,
they're confused
and undisciplined.
Yeah, you really got 'em there.
Those soldiers went from
tightly choreographed parade
to tourists trying to decide
where to have lunch.
And all it took was a tiny bit
of chemical warfare.
It's brilliant.
But even as the army
was dicking around,
trying to invent
a literal love bomb,
some researchers
were using LSD
as a mental health treatment.
In 1966, CBS News
actually followed a man
who received LSD
as part of his treatment
for alcoholism,
and reported on
its startling results.
NARRATOR 2: Six months
after treatment with LSD,
six months after his release
from the alcoholics ward
at Spring Grove Hospital,
Arthur King has started over.
At the age of 33,
he has gone back to school,
something he talked about doing
for years.
In evening classes,
he's studying accounting.
Have you had anything
to drink, for example?
No, I haven't.
Nothing at all.
And I haven't had any desire
to drink anything.
That is incredible.
But also, that guy is 33?
I know that I am hardly
one to talk
as a legal 45,
but a spiritual octogenarian,
but holy shit!
People sure aged a lot worse
back when we painted
everything with lead
and let people smoke
in the delivery room.
Unfortunately,
by the late 1960s,
psychedelics became
increasingly associated
with the counterculture,
and as the government
cracked down on that movement,
they began an era
of anti-psychedelic hysteria.
And it was intense.
Junk studies made dubious
but terrifying claims
like that LSD could warp
your chromosomes.
And education films
employed a wide range
of tones and scare tactics
like these.
SPEAKER 2: This is a fetus
from a mother
not receiving LSD.
A normal fetus.
This is a fetus from the mother
receiving LSD.
I know doctors,
and I know lawyers,
and I know the most stable
people in the world
that have taken trips on LSD
and are still waiting to return.
NARRATOR 3: Unfortunately,
these dreamy psychedelic trips
are very often one-way.
Okay, okay.
That is quite
the smear campaign there
from the hamster fetus
that looks like dino nuggets,
to the woman screaming at you
about all the doctors
and lawyers she knows,
to the hearse that apparently
makes house calls.
And while all of that
was nonsense,
I do kind of miss the days
when we used to
get dressed up to watch
our drugged-out relatives
get carted off to the morgue.
"Honey, they'll be hauling
Jimmy's body
to its final stop
before hippie hell.
Quick, where's my tie clip?
Helen, tie clip!
The neighbors may see,
they're gonna think we're poor!
Get it together, Helen,
and find my tie clip!
The boy is dead!"
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Tall tales about LSD
ran rampant.
At one point, a Pennsylvania
state commissioner...
But the truth is,
he made it up.
He later admitted the hoax
saying he'd attended a lecture
on the use of LSD by children
and became so concerned
he wanted to scare people away
from the drug.
But the hysteria hit
its absolute peak
when Nixon passed...
...alongside drugs like heroin.
Essentially stopping
medical research
dead in its tracks.
One researcher described
the work
as being put in the
"deep freeze."
And when scientist
started working with MDMA,
it too got swept up
into the panic
with the journal Science
alleging that
just one use can cause
permanent brain damage
in monkeys.
A study that got a lot
of attention
before being retracted
after it was found that
the monkeys hadn't actually
taken MDMA at all,
but instead had been given meth.
And that is a very
different drug.
Any study's result
is gonna change
if the independent variable
is suddenly and unexpectedly
fucking meth!
"We've studied the vaccine
for COVID
and the participants
are going ape shit for it!"
But in recent years,
perceptions have finally
begun to shift,
with the FDA granting
breakthrough status
to support the study of MDMA
for treating PTSD
and doing the same
for psilocybin
to treat depression.
And at this point,
let's talk about exactly
why psychedelics
can be so effective.
Different ones can work
in different ways,
but for instance,
research shows that MDMA
dampens the response
in the amygdala,
which is the threat-detecting
sensor of the brain.
Meaning you're able to confront
and process trauma
that you can't otherwise face.
Here is one researcher
explaining how it works
with a story about taking
MDMA recreationally
in his younger days.
BEN SESSA: I can remember
at one time, after a rave,
all of us lying around
all loved up,
and somebody said,
"Oh, wow, this is amazing,
it's so beautiful,
everything's so perfect."
And someone said,
"Let's think of
the worst possible thing
we can imagine."
And someone said,
"Let's imagine our moms dying."
And then someone said,
"It's not that bad."
And I didn't know it then,
but that really was
what MDMA does.
It allows you to think about
and go to
those dark, difficult,
forbidden, avoidant memories
that you normally
wouldn't be able to touch.
That is fascinating.
And I'm so glad that
that worked out for him,
but "Let's imagine
our moms dying,"
doesn't sound like
an amazing time.
It sounds like a rave
DJ'd by Werner Herzog.
(IMITATING WERNER HERZOG)
"Life is fleeting.
Let's imagine our moms dying
as a solemn reminder
that all we have is tonight.
Now, wave your hands in the air
as if our slow passage
towards oblivion
makes you just not care."
(AIR HORN BLARES)
Now, to be clear,
psychedelic therapy
involves much more
than just taking a pill.
These drugs alone
don't automatically
produce results.
Usually, treatment entails
multiple sessions
lasting most of the day.
In which you may take MDMA
or psilocybin
under the supervision
of medical professionals,
and then follow up
with processing and after care.
They are not a replacement
for conventional talk therapy.
They just seem to make you
significantly more receptive
to it.
Just watch
this former firefighter
narrate video of himself
undergoing
MDMA assisted therapy.
This is your first
medicated treatment session?
Correct. This is the beginning
of some interesting revelations
on this video.
And are you feeling
completely conscious
and you're in control and...?
Yeah. And I felt like
I was able to relax
even when I was talking
through probably
my most traumatic memories.
I don't think I had seen
a dead person until then.
The first one
was gruesome too.
It was like being able
to take a big breath, you know,
after being stuck under water
for a long time.
Yeah.
And you can see the utility
of having two people
either side of that man
talking him through
the experience.
And if it sounds like
I'm treating
having two people to talk to
about your feelings
like a radical idea,
you do have to remember
that I was born tragically
and medically British.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
What is interesting is, though,
it is not just
that your fear is muted.
Your brain's ability
to make other connections
and forge new neural pathways
is also heightened.
Meaning that these sessions
can fundamentally alter
the way you process things.
That is thought to be
one reason
why psychedelics
are so promising
for treating conditions
like addiction and depression.
And why they are proving
especially useful
for dealing with trauma.
That is what makes
this form of therapy
particular appealing
to veterans.
As PTSD is
an urgent issue for them.
A rate substantially higher
from the general population.
And it's not like the VA's
current treatment methods
are particularly effective.
Remember the guy from earlier
who compared
psychedelic treatment
to a "bathtub full of puppies"?
Listen to him describe
the mental health care
from the VA
that he initially received.
I drove to Womack Army
Medical Center at Fort Bragg.
And I said
I was gonna kill myself.
They gave me six Xanax
and told me not to take them all
at the same time
because it might kill me.
They asked if
I had guns at home
and I said, "Yes, a lot."
And they asked if I had ammo,
I said, "Yeah, plenty."
They said, "Okay,
when you get home,
give all your guns
to a neighbor."
This is like four o'clock
in the morning.
And they said,
"Come back after the holidays."
Okay.
I knew the VA's mental health
services were subpar,
but I didn't know
they stooped to,
"Here's a bunch of ways
to kill yourself,
but honor system, don't,
and anyway,
see you after the saddest time
of the year."
Thankfully, that guy
saw such a profound change
from MDMA therapy
that he is now
helping to lead a movement
to allow psychedelics to be used
to treat conditions like PTSD,
eliciting help from
Democratic lawmakers like AOC,
and even Republican lawmakers
like Rick Perry
and Dan Crenshaw.
And that kind of
bipartisan consensus
has brought us to
the tipping point
that we're at right now
because so far, in the U.S.,
these drugs have only
legally been available to people
in clinical trials.
But over the next year,
it is widely anticipated
that the FDA will approve
MDMA for clinical use
with psilocybin expected
to follow a few years later.
And maybe even LSD one day.
Meaning that we may be about
to finally realize
some of the huge potential
of psychedelics,
which is great,
but it is worth being
very careful at this point
to make sure that
we don't repeat past mistakes
or indeed, make new ones.
And those who work
in this field
point to a few big areas
for caution.
The first concerns
how psychedelics
are administered,
and by whom.
Because while people
have used these drugs
recreationally forever
and will continue to
at parties, at raves,
in nature,
or to really liven up
a baptism,
psychedelic assisted therapy
is not for everyone.
For example,
anyone with a history
of schizophrenia
or psychosis
may want to steer clear.
And even if you are
a good match,
because these drugs
can put you in
an incredibly vulnerable state,
experts emphasize the importance
of trying them
in a controlled setting,
which ideally would involve
two people present at all times,
and even videotaping
the session,
like that one
that you just saw earlier.
They advise this
not just for your own safety,
but also because for all
their potential benefits,
these drugs aren't always
a bathtub full of puppies.
We tell people that
their experiences
may vary from very positive
to transcendent and lovely
to literally
hell realm experiences.
Hell realm?
As frightening an experience
as you have ever had
in your life.
Now, that does sound bad,
although, to be fair,
you don't need to take drugs
to get to the hell realm.
After all, that is why
airports have Sbarros.
But it is important to note
that even those in studies
who've reported hell realm
type experiences
have often still felt
that they benefited
from the treatment.
But safety is not
the only worry here.
There are also concerns
over accessibility.
These treatments are likely
to be very expensive.
And there are some players
angling to make them
even more so.
Just look at
Compass Pathways.
A for-profit psychedelic company
backed by Peter Thiel.
It...
...which already seems
pretty aggressive
for a drug that, remember,
has been around
for thousands of years.
And Compass' executives
seemed pretty defensive
when they were pressed
about this.
Do you really believe
that your form of psilocybin
is novel and non-obvious?
Well, it doesn't really matter
what we believe.
What does matter is what
the U.S. Patent Office believes,
what the U.K. Patent Office
believes,
what Germany,
what Hong Kong believes.
And all of them believe
that actually it is
because we have
the granted patents.
Okay.
But we shouldn't necessarily
trust the U.S. Patent Office
as an arbiter
of good judgment.
This is the same place
that issued patents for
an umbrella for your beer,
a tricycle with a lawnmower
attached to it,
and a stick.
That's it, just a stick
for animals to play with.
Someone at the Patent Office
saw that and said,
"We've never seen
a stick before. Approved!"
So take what they believe
is important
with a big pinch of salt.
And look, it is not just
the drug formulation.
Compass has also tried
to patent other aspects
of what's often called,
"the set and setting
of treatment."
From the room comprising
soft furniture
or being decorated using
muted colors,
to the subjects lying
on a bed or on a couch,
or a therapist responding
to things a patient is saying.
Which is just the entire
fucking concept of therapy!
It'd be like me patenting
the concept
of wearing a suit
while sitting at a desk.
I'm clearly not the only person
who does this.
Now, if I were to patent
the concept of doing that
while making you wonder
why the fuck your TV is still on
after The Last of Us has ended,
then, yeah,
that would be uniquely
my thing.
Now, those set and setting
patent applications
are still pending.
But the very fact they applied
for them at all
is a pretty clear sign
of just how aggressive
companies in this space
intend to be going forward.
And it is not like
these treatments
are going to be cheap
to start with.
Experts project a course
of psychedelic therapy
is likely to cost upwards
of 15,000 dollars.
And given that,
as we've discussed before
on this show,
there is currently
a massive shortage
of mental health professionals
in this country,
due in part to how fucked up
our health insurance system is,
you can see how
this could quickly and easily
become a big mess,
or only accessible
to the wealthiest Americans.
So there is a lot
to figure out here
even before you get
into questions like:
Who will regulate
psychedelic therapy?
Because the FDA
is in charge of drugs,
but it doesn't regulate
the practice of medicine.
Now, state laws
could cover it,
state regulatory agencies could,
or professional
organizations might.
But someone has to.
Because if they don't,
people are likely to get hurt,
which could then send us
all the way back
to fearmongering, bans,
and research getting put on ice.
Which is the last thing
that we should want to happen.
Because there is massive
potential here.
These treatments have shown
that they can sometimes
have lasting effects.
Remember the world's oldest
33-year-old
that you saw earlier?
Whose LSD treatments seem
to have curbed his alcoholism?
CBS caught up with him
a quarter century later
to see how things were going,
and the answer was, pretty well.
ARTHUR KING: LSD allowed me
to see my own mind.
There was a problem that I had
to resolve, and I faced it,
and it disappeared.
As far as I'm concerned,
I wouldn't take
a million dollars
for the peace of mind
that I obtained
from this therapy.
CBS REPORTER: It was that good,
that refreshing,
-that rejuvenating.
-And that enduring.
Exactly.
Thirty years later,
he was still feeling benefits
from the treatment,
which is striking.
And you'd think
that we'd have acted
on evidence like that,
but instead,
it seems we've spent
the last half century
terrifying people
with bogus science
and giving meth to monkeys.
But the good news is,
we are finally moving forward
and hopefully we will do that
with real caution and real care.
Because if we do, maybe,
just maybe,
one day you will see ads
for psychedelic therapy on TV
with a voice over warning you
the side effects may include
visits to the hell realm
and rainbows
shooting out of your dick.
♪ (PIANO RUN) ♪